joining us here on the rich eisen show
and his first season
as a driver of the 23 doordash toyota
camry for the 2311 racing team
of denny hamlin and michael jordan that
michael jordan is
bubba wallace that bubba wallace how are
you bubba
i'm good mr rich how you doing i am
doing better for talking to you what has
it been like to uh
race uh in this car for this uh new team
so far well a lot of fun i will say that
and a lot of potential a lot of growth
for us so all those things
it shapes up for an exciting year i'm
i'm really looking forward to
uh especially the next couple races on
the schedule starting at martinsville
this weekend
gonna be a great a great outing for us i
have a lot of faith
and some good vibes you know going into
this weekend so
beyond excited but uh but really just
just thankful for the opportunity you
know without our partners in place you
know you mentioned doordash
uh you know toyota dr pepper mcdonald's
root
um it's been
it's been a crazy whirlwind ever since
we announced what in november
to where we're at now we're still
playing ketchup but man we we've really
been hitting on a lot of good notes so
i'm excited about it now obviously you
know uh
you had options and um obviously bubba
you're you know uh i'd imagine i i
i guess you can't say obviously i'd
imagine so i'll say this
i would imagine when it first uh passed
your ear gate got into your head that
michael jordan would be interested in
having you drive for a new team
with him and denny hamlin you were kind
of that that would make you pause for a
second
what was that like uh in your
conversations with mj i
imagine you've had many uh if not just a
handful of them what was that like
bubba yeah well leading up to to the
deal we we didn't
i didn't have a conversation with them
it was just mainly with denny and myself
and uh denny was was you know before it
was
all signed filled and delivered he was
all you know gung-ho about it and ready
to roll and i just kept trying to tell
him
hey man as long as we got to get things
signed before i'll get excited and jump
on the hype train with you but ever
since it's been signed it's been a lot
of fun i will never forget
you know all the text messages that i
got after we did announce the
the one text message that stood out the
most was from an unknown number at the
time and it just said at the end of it
just said mj and i'm like well there's
only one mj that i know
so that that was uh that was pretty
special so to have him you know
really in my back pocket you know for
somebody to talk to and
whatnot is really really cool so what
what might he have
uh has he imparted any sort of uh
competition
advice in any way shape or form at all
because obviously
no this is a new plan for him
yeah as big as a fan as he is of the
sport and he'll tell you he's been
watching ever since you know
as a kid coming down with his with his
father uh
he loves that story and such a great
story of how he got hooked into nascar
but
you know he's still learning everything
you know especially from an ownership
standpoint
and actually having skin in the game you
know he's learning about everything and
i'm sure he's
he's definitely blowing up denny's phone
a lot more uh than mine
uh just making sure that everything's on
track and and that we're shaped up
for success because i think out of both
mj and denny those guys don't accept
failure and neither do i so
i'm excited to be where i'm at and you
know we we always strive to be greater
than we were
uh the previous day and and you always
got to do that no matter what it is in
life
so um you know he's he's all invested
he's all in
uh everybody in this organization is all
in to continue to grow and make it
bigger than what it is i mean that's
going to be
a neat thing too i mean um to be honest
with you i mean
to try and compare notes with you i mean
i i helped launch
nfl network and and you know this show
is coming up on seven years
there's nothing more gratifying than
starting something new and from scratch
that you have you know if not physical
ownership
mental ownership of and i'm wondering
what that's been like
for you bubba yeah it's
just kind of you know seeing or
everything has
you know gone throughout my 17 years 18
years
i don't know math is hard at times you
know you know i just thought about to go
sidetrack for a second go for it
now i know i'm young compared to who i'm
talking to yeah yeah yeah but that's
like i just thought i've been 10 years
out of school
geez that's a long time so math is math
is really hard for me
right now so back back to where i was 17
years i've been doing it
um you know the the ups and downs
the the trials and tribulations that you
go through
um it's not even just me it's just you
know whatever you
come through at life and whatever you
chase is a dream in life
like you're it's not a it's not a
cakewalk
and that's that's where you learn and
grow as a human being
and you know it's funny that's the way
you figure out life is how to
how to navigate through the ups and
downs and so to see where i'm at now
uh is is really a blessing you know i
mentioned our partners before
being decked out in columbia gear the
whole night i've been having
having just everybody a part of it to
see where i'm at having potential in the
team having people that believe in me
you know it's super special it's it's an
honor tumbling it's
it's a heck of an experience and
something that i'll cherish and continue
to
stay focused on for as long as i can
bubba wallace here on the rich eisen
show
athletes in all sports team or
individual 2020 was a unique year to say
the least
and unique is you can unpack that word
quite a bit
i would have to sit here and say again
individual team sports
uh any athlete um in 2020
you would i'd put you in the top five of
journey
um wild um uh
also um i would say potentially
anxious anxiety what did you learn from
2020 you said about growing as a person
your 2020 campaign um that did end up
obviously with you signing with a new
team
what did you learn about yourself bubba
wallace
that there's no there's no such thing as
pressure anymore
uh when you have the uh the weight of
the world on your shoulders and you have
basically all the eyes in the world
watching you
you know go through all those things
and to still be able to come out and
produce really good race results
for our team at the time you know it
just shows
people talk about man there's got to be
so much pressure
racing or driving for mj in the position
you're in now and i said
if you watched last year this is nothing
but a cake walk now so i'm all right
right so everything from here on out
becomes that just what much more
um easier for the lack of better phrase
it just
it because you've already been yeah i'd
say that you know i don't exactly know
how to put it but
i mean that's that's the easiest way to
put it i mean it's just
to be honest with you rich it was it was
so much
so much going on like like sometimes i
didn't even you know focus on getting
sleep because i was just doing so much i
was just being pulled in so
so many different directions or you know
i would you know sit here and live with
my girlfriend and you know
forget to say hey to her just just
because there was so much
that had your mind elsewhere and it was
just like
wow so to be able to navigate through
that and people ask what one of my
what one of my strengths is and i say
compartmentalizing things
being able to focus on one thing if i
have 10 things on the schedule
somehow and i have a race at the end of
that schedule somehow
my mind is still ready to go and
to be able to produce a result for the
race like compartmentalizing things and
not letting things get built up too much
i i've crashed i've had that crashing
moment where things have gotten too much
but for the most part
it's been it's been on a positive time
and um you know where do you stand on
the subject
of mixing uh real world stuff um
and and and sports where where do you
now stand having gone through 2020
finding yourself at the forefront of
conversations uh about the american flag
about um so much and of the i mean the
you know the uh the confederate flag i
meant obviously
and the uh and where do you stand on the
subject matter of using your platform to
speak about something
outside of nascar uh or sports
where do you stand on that subject yeah
well
so i have what i've been saying we are
we are the entertainment people love to
get away
from real world problems to turn on
football
to turn on baseball basketball nascar
and they're like yes i don't have to
deal
with whatever problems i have going on
for the next
three to four hours i get to watch my
favorite athletes
perform well
the athletes are saying this is our
everyday life
and we have real world problems too
and if i gain a following from my
profession
and i say one thing and that's going to
get people to stand up and listen and
take
take pride in that and want to be a part
of something much greater than
themselves then
absolutely i'm going to do that so this
whole
mixing politics with sports it's not
politics it's again it's being a human
being
it's experiencing what life is thrown at
you yes
my my voice carries weight other than
jim bob down the road here like yeah
like that's just that's how society is i
believe that we are all the same
we put on our pants the same way we
bleed the same way we cry the same way
but just because i'm an athlete and i
drive cars and i'm on television on
sundays
means i am means i am already
automatically greater than
anybody else that's around me which i
don't believe that i believe
no matter what i do what i say it's the
same as
if somebody else said it but the way
society had put
us on this pedestal um you know our
voices
impact on a much greater level and
i've i've had to find my way of you know
overstepping boundaries throughout my
ear and knowing like
oh okay this is totally different from
thinking that i'm just
bubba wallace the guy just who just
happens to be a race car driver on the
weekends
no i'm i'm the race car driver every day
of the week and
uh and so using my platform to create
you know good um for for all of us
i'll continue to do that until i i can't
do it anymore
including the live to be different
foundation everybody could uh follow
baba wallace on twitter and instagram
bubba wallace best of luck in
martinsville i know you got to run right
now let's do this again soon
always enjoy our chats yeah absolutely
always pleasure to talk to you thank you
right back at you that's bubba wallace
right here you can watch it on fs1 at 7
30 pm eastern time on saturday night
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here